in March 2023 an open letter sounded the
alarm on the training of giant AI
experiments it was signed by over 30,000
individuals including more than 2,000
industry leaders and more than 3,000
experts since then there has been a
growing concern about out ofcontrol AI
development Advanced AI could pose quote
profound risk to society and Humanity
they say we could potentially face a
dystopic future or even EXT
people are right to be afraid these
Advanced systems could make humans
extinct and with threats escalating it
could be sooner than we think autonomous
weapons large-scale cyber attacks and AI
enabled biot terrorism endanger human
lives
today rampant misinformation and
pervasive bias are eroding trust and
weakening our society we Face an
international emergency AI developers
are aware and admit these dangers and
we're we're putting it out there before
we actually know whether it's safe and
the bad case and I think this is like
important to say is like lights out for
all of us a straightforward
extrapolation of today's systems to
those we expect to see in 2 to 3 years
suggests a substantial risk that AI
systems will be able to fill in all the
missing pieces enabling many more actors
to carry out large-scale biological
attacks in 6 hours he says the computer
came up with designs for 40,000 highly
toxic mod mules they remain locked in an
arms race to create more and more
powerful systems with no clear plan for
safety or control it can be very harmful
if deployed wrongly and we don't have
all the answers there yet and the
technology is moving fast so does that
keep me up at night absolutely they
recognize a Slowdown will be necessary
to prevent harm but are unable or
unwilling to say when or how there is
public consensus and the call is loud
and
clear regulate AI
now we've seen regulation driven
innovation in areas like Pharmaceuticals
and Aviation why would we not want the
same for AI there are major downsides we
have to manage to be able to get the
upsides there are three key areas we are
looking for us lawmakers to act one
immediately establish a registry of
giant AI experiments maintained by a US
Federal agency two
they must build a licensing system to
make Labs prove their systems are safe
before deployment three they must take
steps to make sure developers are
legally liable for the harms their
products
cause finally we must not stop at home
this affects everyone at the upcoming UK
Summit every concerned Nation must have
a seat we are looking to create an
international multi-stakeholder auditing
agency this kind of international Co
operation has been possible in the past
we coordinated on cloning and we banned
bioweapons and now we can work together
on
[Music]
AI